ja ich habe mich gewundert was der
klimaschutz plötzlich alles möglich
macht aber zuerst robert habeck der
wirtschaftsminister der jetzt auch für
klima zuständig ist und er hat gesagt ja
wir windräder bauen wollen dann müssen
wir auch mal die rücksicht auf den
rotmilan beispielsweise der gern
geschreddert wird von solchen
rotorflügel müssen ein stück weit zurück
stecken wir finden jetzt eine ganz
raffinierte lösung wir verrechnen die
rotmilan bestände einfach europaweit und
weil die franzosen viele atomkraftwerke
nach an der roten landal ungestört
brüten und bei uns wird halt gewechselt
also rot wieder in schutz artenschutz
eigentlich ein hohes gut zurückgestellt
auf baumfällungen für windräder sind
viel einfacher das finde ich
bemerkenswert gegen all die jahre nicht
und scheiterte meistens auch an den
grünen jetzt hat die
bundesumweltministerin gesagt die hat
sie wieder ungehorsam gehört dazu und
wenn sich junge menschen mit
sekundenkleber auf den straßen
festkleben diese blockieren für einen
guten zweck gegen
lebensmittelverschwendung oder gegen den
klimawandel dann ist das schon okay also
hat sie hohes verständnis für das finde
ich interessant das waren unangemeldete
illegale sitzblockaden mit hohem aufwand
für die polizei die mit sonnenblumenöl
und verdünnung mühsam mit einem pinsel
die am kreaturen da wieder von der
straße kratzen mussten im wahrsten sinne
des wortes und der verkehr gestaut
riesenärger bis hin zu problemen mit dem
sanitäts autos die nicht durchkamen und
eine bundesministerin hat verständnis
für illegale aktionen liebe
spaziergänger aufgepasst ziviler
ungehorsam gehört dazu sagt die
bundesumweltministerin würde ich mir mal
merken für die nächste für die nächste
zeit und dann stellen wir jetzt als
klima botschafterin für die
klimaverhandlungen aller welt die
greenpeace chefin ein die hatten auch
noch einen etat von 6 milliarden für
internationale klimaprojekte in
schwellenländern das finde ich eine
tolle sache ich hoffe nur dass sie
einfach die greenpeace agenda nicht im
amt einfach fortsetzt sondern auch noch
ein stück weit deutsche interessen mit
im blick behält sie ist amerikanerin und
muss jetzt mit hochdruck eingebürgert
werden all das ist plötzlich möglich
weil der klimaschutz verlangt also ich
bin gespannt was uns da an kreativen
ideen von der ambo regierung noch alles
in nächster zeit bevorsteht ja und ich
glaube tatsächlich also volle zustimmung
und ich glaube dass das eines der
größten probleme ist da sind wir auch
wieder beim thema vertrauen in die
demokratie und in unsere institution
wenn die leute merken da gibt es
verschiedene standards und dieser satz
der zweck heiligt die mittel ist einer
der gefährlichsten für die ganze für den
ganzen gesellschaftlichen diskurs in dem
sinne und wir erleben einfach dass der
doppelte standards angelegt werden wenn
völlig anders mit friday the future
demonstrationen umgegangen wird alles
mit mit denen ich inhaltlich nichts zu
tun habe aber als mit querdenker
demonstration die leute sehen das ist im
grunde genommen ist eine demonstration
und die muss eben geschützt sein und da
kann man nicht anders mit der einen
umgehen als mit der anderen genauso
lässt man freilich verfügt als
organisation dinge durchgehend die
anderen organisationen die längst dann
nicht mehr existieren könnten
antisemitismus-vorwürfe mit cdu der
verfassungsschutz in hamburg hat schon
früh auch vor einer unterwanderung von
linksextremen organisation da gewarnt
das sind alles sachen die würden bei
jeder anderen organisation extrem
kritisch diskutiert werden und da sind
sicher viele dabei mit guten motiven
aber man darf eben nicht sagen nur weil
die für die richtige sache stehen aus
der sicht des betrachters jeweils ist
alles in ordnung das geht nicht ich
mache mir vor einigen sorgen tatsächlich
dass das was jetzt an ungutem gelernt
wurde in der korona krise nach dem motto
lebensgefährlich rechtfertigt also
weitestgehende grundrechtseingriffe dass
das jetzt als modell genommen und
übertragen wird auf klimafragen denn ich
weiß gar nicht wann das in unserer
politik sozusagen demokratisch
beschlossen worden ist dass die
klimakrise jetzt sozusagen das größte in
deutschland in deutschland und von
deutschland zu lösende problem ist aber
offenbar sehen das viele so oft viele
publizistische kollegen sehen das
inzwischen so und es wird durchaus
diskutiert in den unterschiedlichsten
kreisen also von von kirchen bis zur
nationalakademie leopoldina und auch bei
den grünen und auch robert habeck hat
das in seinem letzten buch zumindest
angedeutet dass man im prinzip also wenn
das denn ähnlich dramatisch ist wenn es
bei der klimakrise jetzt so ähnlich um
leben und tod geht wie bei corona man
natürlich überlegen kann ob man
grundrechte auch weiter einschränkt und
da sehe ich sozusagen also den die
größten und gefährlichsten gefährdeten
zusammenhang zu dem was jetzt gelernt
werden worden ist was dringend wieder
verlernt werden muss bevor es also
unbedingt weiter angewendet wird dann
auf die klimakrise denn dann können wir
uns wirklich
von demokratischen verhältnissen
mittelfristig verabschieden denn jetzt
heißt es immer not kennt kein gebot und
was man da wählt oder beschließt ist
dann egal also für mich sind es ja
wirklich ideologische grabenkämpfe die
wir hier veranstalten aus ist man es hat
schon begonnen mit fritz fischer
ich habe das natürlich bei unseren
unternehmen auch live miterlebt die
radikal teilweise auch vorgegangen wurde
unternehmer bashing betrieben wurde
obwohl wir als familienunternehmen schon
viele jahre bevor es überhaupt freie so
fischer gab investiert haben neue
klimaschutzmaßnahmen in neue
technologien aber ich muss auch an
dieser stelle nochmal sagen ich
diskutiere wirklich viel über das klima
das klima dem klima ist es relativ egal
wo dieser co2 ausgestoßen wird ja es ist
ein globales problem und wir brauchen
globale lösungen und was wir machen in
deutschland wir verfolgen einen
nationalen alleingang und wir machen
unseren wirtschaftsstandort kaputt damit
deswegen lassen uns doch globale
lösungen anpassen wir hatten damals
dieses großartige projekt desertec
desertec hatte das ziel wüstenstrom zu
generieren in afrika wohlstand zu
schaffen arbeitsplätze dort solaranlagen
zu bauen grünstrom zu exportieren da
könnten wir in europa in der ganzen welt
diesen strom auch nutzen was ist
passiert das ganze ist am politischen
willen gescheitert dieses projekt gibt
es aber jetzt auch wieder und ich würde
mir tatsächlich wünschen dass wir dieses
projekt auch vorantreiben weil was
machen wir wir schalten unsere
kohlekraftwerke ab unsere atomkraftwerke
wir machen uns abhängig eigentlich von
anderen ländern und das kann doch nicht
die lösung sein wir müssen wirklich
jetzt globale lösungen entwickeln plus
und ob er natürlich ein gutes instrument
ein marktwirtschaftliches den
europäischen globalen emissionshandel
das müsste man wirklich anpacken um die
klimakrise zu bewältigen und nicht hier
in deutschland klein klein irgendwelche
von der straße zu ziehen also es ist
wirklich und das aus unternehmersicht
mal wir machen unseren
wirtschaftsstandort kaputt müssen da
jetzt wirklich was unsere lage effektiv
und wir schlagen uns effektive
instrumente auch noch selbst aus der
hand wir haben im kohleausstieg haben
wir festgelegt dass deutschland sich an
keinerlei kohletechnologie auf der welt
mehr beteiligt wir wurden bei der
letzten reise der kann dann nach
südafrika gebeten ob wir die 85 prozent
kohle strom erzeugen hoch dreckig
zehnmal so viel co2 dass wir dort
filteranlagen zur verfügung stellen um
das zu filtern da könnten wir den co2
aus stoss mindestens halbieren den
südafrika hat nein wir haben uns ja
geschworen wir beteiligen uns an
keinerlei kohletechnologie auf der welt
mehr die kanzlerin musste dankend
ablehnen und hat dann darauf verwiesen
vielleicht können die briten oder
franzosen helfen das wäre wirklich
effektiv ich erschreckend finde wenn wir
uns anschauen momentan sind in asien
606 100 und wir diskutieren über
fahrradfahren e auto auf die straße ist
doch verrückt unser anteil sind zwei
prozent am weltweiten ausstoß das müssen
wir uns bewusst machen und wir schlagen
uns als unternehmer herum wir
investieren unser kapital in technologie
freundliche maschinen et cetera wir tun
und machen aber wir machen mit dieser
politik die wir verfolgen unsere
wirtschafts stadtradio
familienunternehmen sind da übrigens
absolut führend also nun in den kleinen
maßstäben natürlich die den den benefit
auch haben von solchen klima schonen den
maßnahmen das ist wirklich zum teil
grandios was was kleinere betriebe also
500 mitarbeitern und etwa in der
größenordnung der leisten von
solarpanelen bis geothermie und das
fällt jetzt nicht so groß auf aber es
ist ein riesen beitrag und es ist schon
aus eigeninteresse weil man einfach
kosten spart wenn man ökologisch
wirtschaftet das sieht aber keiner und
stattdessen gibt es dann immer wieder
proteste und wir müssen in der mensa
mindestens drei vegetarische tage
einführen um das weltklima zu retten